lo que queremos hacer en este vídeo es
averiguar cuánto es 2 dividido entre 0.4
o todos dividido entre cuatro décimas
pausa este vídeo y trata de resolverlo
como una pequeña pista piensa en dos en
la recta numérica y piensa en cuántos
saltos de cuatro décimas tienes que
hacer desde cero para llegar a dos para
averiguar cuánto es 2 dividido entre
cuatro décimas bien hagámoslo juntos y
como mencioné en mi sugerencia sólo
pensemos en cuantos saltos de cuatro
décimas tenemos que hacer para ir de 0 a
2 y en esta recta numérica cada una de
estas es una décima porque podemos ver
que hay diez espacios iguales entre 0 y
1 así que vamos a dar algunos saltos de
4 décimas
entonces si empezamos en cero podemos
hacer veamos que hay una décima dos
décimas tres décimas cuatro décimas esto
es un salto lo voy a enumerar y luego
podemos hacer nuestro siguiente salto de
uno dos tres cuatro décimas es justo
aquí
dos saltos entonces nuestro próximo
salto nos llevará justo aquí así que
estoy haciendo saltos iguales de cuatro
décimas mi próximo salto nos llevará a
uno dos tres cuatro décimas más eso nos
llevará justo aquí y hemos dado cuatro
saltos y luego parece que nuestro quinto
salto nos llevará aquí uno dos tres
cuatro décimas si nuestro quinto salto
nos lleva exactamente a dos así que
hemos hecho cinco saltos de cuatro
décimas para pasar de 0 a 2 otra forma
de pensar es que se dividiera todos en
partes iguales de cuatro décimas
podrías dividirlo en cinco partes
iguales de cuatro décimas o puedes hacer
cinco saltos iguales de cuatro décimas
para ir de cero a dos